John Levine reports reporters covering
Elon Musk being nuked Dania Sullivan for
CNN Drew Harwell for Washington Post
Ryan Mack the New York Times and Aaron
rupar independent all gone awesome the
gun take a look at this so uh Libs of
tick tock says Taylor Lorenz just
scrubbed her entire Twitter account what
Oh Me Oh My times they are a changing
love it prominent liberal journalist
Aaron rupar suspended by Twitter for
those that aren't familiar with uh Aaron
rupar there's a verb it's called
ruparing or to rupar and it's when you
take an out of context clip and apply
false context to manipulate people that
is ruparing so uh he got nuked and I
think we have a tweet here yasher Ali
says Aaron rupar tells me he has not
received any correspondence from Twitter
and does not know why his account is
suspended I believe rupar is the guy
that sued didn't he sue the previous
Twitter Administration to get his
account back I might think of a
difference someone else they would never
suspend that guy I'm wondering if the
reason they got suspended was for
posting something pertaining to his
location I don't know for sure but Elon
just the other day posted a video of a
guy who attacked his his family his kid
who looked who looked like an antifa guy
yup he was dressed like one like one
yeah conservatives don't do that
conservative guy in fact I gotta be
honest I put out that tweet where I was
like Nora link was I used to think it
was scary and dangerous but then Elon
agreed with me ideologically now I like
it like I got I'd be willing to bet
anyone on the right who's crazy enough
to track down musk would be like we love
you Elon of course keep it up yeah you
always got false Flags can never truly
judge a book by its cover like
speechless that's true and it was not it
was it was not a bad car so like that's
the one Wrinkle in the in the argument
here some kind of wealth asset but it's
great I don't I don't care at all so you
know I don't want to hear this well you
know we're we thought Elon was going to
be the free speech absolutist and now
he's suspending no I I didn't I don't
know I'm not a free speech absolute I I
believe in standards and norms and you
know what I really believe in banning
these left-wing losers and I really
especially Banning that guy who's
tracking elon's plane that guy's gone
but the rest of them too I see
absolutely no reason for Elon Musk to
tolerate them remaining on Twitter how
do you define free speech well I Define
Free Speech as uh the I Define free
speech I suppose as the founding fathers
might have defined Free Speech which is
or even as John Locke the father of
liberalism might have defined Free
Speech which is not totally free which
is yes we have broad Toleration for lots
of different things but there are limits
and they're pretty severe limits I mean
let's not forget we're not only talking
about speech acts like fraud or direct
threats or obscenity or things like that
people a lot of people don't even think
of obscenity these days as something not
protected by Free Speech but I would go
further than that all right yes it's
true that the libs have speech codes but
chivalry is a speech code too you know
and I'm all for chivalry I'm all for
Banning people who who are degrading our
society I mean you know just as a matter
of historical fact
speech earlier on in American history
was much more restricted in certain ways
than than it is right now we had a
blasphemy laws for much of the Americans
and obscenity we still have obscenity
laws on the books they just don't
enforce them now in fact now they only
enforce it if you have wholesome speech
if you if you speak obscenely then you
get to do it that's why I say culture is
more important because we got a ton of
laws on the books they started ignoring
personally I I disagree because who who
do you decide who's degrading Society
with what ideas I think if there's bad
with your reason and your moral
conscience yeah but who's going to be
calling the shots here I think the
people who aren't here exactly and power
uh corrupts absolute power corrupts
absolutely but when it comes to bad
ideas they need to be challenged with
good ideas I think we need open debate I
think we need open conversation and I'm
very curious to see what happened here
and I'm more skeptical because I believe
at the end of the day even though we
might might not agree with each other I
still rather have that conversation
rather than say I just only want to hear
myself do we need to have a conversation
about the virtues of child pornography
do we need to have that debate that's a
debate we really need to have that is
one issue that obviously I I stand with
with you on uh but I know you're
obviously you stand with me on yeah
child pornography obviously but do you
do you think we need to have the debate
you know in the free Marketplace I don't
think we do I think if there's idiots
out there right who do believe in
concerned which there is right
they didn't they they deserve to be
challenged they deserve to be pushed
they deserve it because because but
again
um if you push people away just like you
do with the censorship that's been
happening you push people to more
radicalized corners of the internet and
they double down on that on their ideas
rather than having a whole bunch of
people telling them hey this is wrong
and not acceptable here by pushing them
away they won't have that kind of
pushback in their life and they're like
okay I'm just gonna hang around other
you know CD people and think this is
okay when it's not I I actually would
agree with you Michael on this one I I
see Luke's point but I think it can be
refined like there's a reason why we
publicly denounce the reason why you're
saying right now we don't need to have a
debate it's set up we've figured it out
yeah but that's one issue but that's all
the issues no for sure and that means
that there will come a time when you
need to explain to someone who maybe
says well people should be allowed to
have their opinions and you can be like
look there are some things that are so
morally reprehensible that it's
universally despised in among most human
beings and you know we will tell you why
it's bad
I mean this this was William F Buckley
Jr who was who's credited as the founder
of the mainstream post-war conservative
movement as Urbane and open-minded
afellow as ever there was he he had a
debate on his show with a
neoconservative uh Leo churn and uh
churn said we need to have the open
society and the free Marketplace of
ideas and Bill Buckley said you know I
actually think we can close Society off
a little bit yes we discuss lots of
things but he said I'm an
epistemological optimist I think that
certain things are settled and we don't
really need to entertain Nazis or
Communists your political opponents are
doing the same exact thing you're doing
in Europe arresting people for saying
that men can't be lesbians they're using
the same justifications and arguments
you are and this is
they're saying using the same procedures
but the substance of what they are doing
is the opposite they're saying I know
what's best for society I know what
ideas are good or bad right you have to
stop these ideas we have to stop
right-wing ideas but there's therefore
if you there hurt people with your idea
is we have to stop you censor you and
throw you into look the difference is
that there's there's a difference
between good and bad so when I if I'm
the CEO of Twitter and I'm determining
what the standards and Norms are on
Twitter and I encourage good true and
beautiful things and I discourage
ugly false and wicked things that's not
the same thing as what the libs do but
that's based off your interpretation
because for them
it's beautiful for them but Luca that's
your interpretation but they're wrong is
the is the thing and so we have
faculties of reason and moral conscience
and we can perceive the world and come
to a Fairly reliable conclusions let me
let me just make a point here uh we like
to believe that the law is that the
world is logical that we can set forth a
set of rules that say you cannot do X Y
and Z and then what we discover is the
interpretations of X Y and Z vary wildly
and we actually struggle to to operate
at humans struggle to operate on a moral
logical level in that if you come out
and say you know don't don't be mean
don't be bad don't hurt somebody and
then someone says okay well insulting
you is my opinion I'm not hurting and
then someone else interprets it as
hurting we see there's an issue there my
view is I air towards mostly free speech
I agree with you on things like child
porn I think there's probably things we
can say Do not advocate for something
like that right yeah if you're
advocating for that on the platform form
we can restrict you or shut you down or
something like this the issue is and
I'll throw it back to the law
we have a bunch of laws on the books
legally you cannot do but they don't
enforce anymore because our culture
changed right which means there is a
centralized morality that human that
societies are willing to tolerate that
means we don't tolerate advocacy for
child porn and there's no reason to open
up tolerance to it we just don't
tolerate it well increasingly it is and
that's and that's the issue so my
pushback for you a little bit is there
will be a debate whether you want it or
not because people will start pushing
but I suppose the the conservative view
from the past 20 years is politics is
Downstream of culture so stop passing
laws it's really just a libertarian view
but it's not passing laws and just you
know I don't know make you know make
better music or something and I'm not
I'm not really mocking it obviously the
culture matters a great deal but you
can't neatly separate these things and
the law is a teacher so if I'm looking
at how we got to this insane cultural
position now where we will be debating
the the virtues of child pornography and
pedos so it's already happening it's
happening they're accusing anybody who
criticizes actual pedophiles they go why
are you talking about gay people but
we've got we got here it's like you you
just mentioned but we got here because
of censorship because of people saying
you can't counter this no no we got here
because those ideas haven't been able to
be challenged because people have been
censored for going against them people
have been arrested for going against why
when when we had a a more uh sensor
sensor-minded regime uh that censored
bad things and promoted good things as
opposed to what we have now which is the
censorship regime that promotes bad
things and suppresses good things like
what's an example what do you mean well
I would say uh let's say the pilgrims
landed Plymouth Rock in 1620 and then
from 1620 up through the founding of The
American Nation up through about I don't
know the early 60s we had a basic
consensus on what is moral and what is
immoral and it was it was Christianity
it was based on the Christian moral View
and then in the 1960s you saw led by the
government led by AI Supreme Court
decisions led by laws that that weakened
some of the censorship regime you saw
the uh you know attacks on McCarthyism
and the house on American Activities
Committee you saw the Free Speech
movement at Berkeley that led to to a
weakening of our obscenity laws you you
saw a weakening of our laws prescribing
certain sexual behaviors that then led
to the sexual Revolution when you opened
up that Society much more what happened
did it lead to this wonderful period of
flourishing no the society has gone
downhill it's gone straight to pot ever
since but the but the parent the dads
used to beat the moms relentlessly did
that was like they just didn't even talk
about it did that happen I mean honorary
like talked about he would smack women
around in there and listen on TV and
Society yeah bad men beat their wives
today and so you know it just seems to
me what you're suggesting is this very
Progressive view that the past was
terrible for the presence before we had
the conversation good people beat their
wives it was it was just accepted now
that we're able to have I don't think
that's true I don't think that's I mean
since the dawn of man and he the guy is
like fall in line or face the
consequences but is your is your
argument in that in the past you know
the past was basically made up of these
knuckle dragging troglodyte men abusing
their wives and ever since we had the
sexual Revolution now
that doesn't happen that just seems like
a very Progressive Fantastical point I
think it was the internet or it was
really television and radio that that
broke the censorship mode whether we we
wanted it or not the technology made us
look at ourselves and be like that's
what we are we need to deal with this
but that's not cool but just really
quick deciding what's good and deciding
what's bad is arbitrary Depends for who
Depends for what Society
because at the end of the day the
government's sitting there and saying
you know Dr fauci is there and he's like
you know at the end of the day it's good
for society if we censor all these other
signs and we let our Doctrine through so
therefore we need to censor this speech
we need to limit Free Speech we need to
ban accounts and essentially that's what
I see you calling for so so here's
here's where I see where we're at uh I I
air towards Free Speech allow people to
express their political views to to be
debated but I think there's a little bit
more limits than many of the anarchists
and Libertarians would be willing to
entertain and the reason I've come to
this position where I used to just be
alive well maybe you can say whatever
you want is because the system as it's
being laid out right now by you in your
view Luke allows the left to say
whatever they want while weaponizing
that to silence anyone who opposes them
meanwhile you're standing there saying
well they're allowed to do it I guess
I'm banned and they're not absolutely
crazy the idea of banning speech is what
created this exact society and that's
why these larger virtues and ideas need
to be pushed what I'm saying
they are cheating of course they're
playing fair and you're losing because
of it also Luke what Society doesn't
have taboos in what Society is
everything perfectly open I mean that's
never existed on Earth anywhere I agree
yeah you're right about that but that
doesn't really sure but that doesn't
mean that doesn't mean we shouldn't
strive towards towards something that's
impossible no no towards respecting
speech and debating ideas let's bring
this back to the to the core story right
the issue is Elon Musk choosing to ban
who he wants and my position because I
think this might argument just go
forever but I think if we can bring this
back to the story Elon Musk needs to set
clearly Define parameters for what he
wants but then we also need judges to
interpret in in the United States we
have laws but laws can be challenged and
judges interpret the law so when a court
when a legislative body says you can't
do X someone says well hold on X could
also include Y and then a judge says
good question I'll give you my ruling
tomorrow the judge then look at the law
looks at the precedent hears the
arguments and then issues his judgment
the law is not just uh if if yes then
you know if one then why if two then it
is it is humans trying their best to
interpret uh the easiest way to put it
is analog it's not digital it's a wave
not a point great which means that that
means we want it to be there's free
speech we respect this but then when you
actually start looking into it you're
like oh hold on now we're getting into
the advocacy for child porn part from
the left at a certain point we're like
it may not be a call for violence
but are we going to tolerate what a
level of advocacy that analogy it's the
it's the analog not the digital it's not
just the law is not just uh you know a
bunch of letters that self-interpret on
a sheet of paper but it involves a human
aspect and what this raises this
interpretive question bring I think
undercuts what you're saying about good
and bad because you you said that good
and bad are just arbitrary but you don't
believe that nobody believes it depends
on who decides it and it depends but let
me ask you one question is it is it
better to cook a pie for a widow than it
is good you have to eat cilantro because
I decided so because I'm empowered
that's essentially what just answer this
question is it is it better to cook a
pie for a widow or to kick a baby in the
head
we all know that it's better even if
she's allergic it's still better to cook
the pie for the Widow than it is to kick
the baby in the head what's the pie made
of is the piece of lamb and mashed
potatoes good shepherd's pie you know
peas and carrots but is it we all know
that Mitch pie is it a brother I don't
even know Marina
well that would be a bad pie but but
even the fact there are some Universal
truths obviously yes so good and bad or
not but when it comes to positions of
power that is usually blurred obviously
whenever you you give power that power
usually is being used against other
individuals so uh when we have people
who uh have a lot of responsibility if
you give them more power and authority
that's not checked that's not counted
especially when it comes to speech it
leads to very tremendously horrible
situation throughout recorded human
history and when you give someone power
to censor criticism of themselves we
have seen the largest human atrocities
because of that but again this is a
debate that's kind of sidetracking our
conversation we could agree to disagree
I respect your your opinions I think you
made some good points as well and and I
think this is an idea maybe we could
even debate afterwards because I know we
still got a crap ton of stories I want
to talk about the Barstool stuff but
I'll just reiterate on the right because
maybe we'll talk in the members only
we'll go nuts with it I just I I want to
believe in free speech I want to say
make your points and we'll argue it but
then I also recognize we we live in a
world of cultural morality we grew up we
have the roots of our parents we have
the Legacy the things that work to make
Humanities uh survive we've retained and
we've shaved off the bat over a long
period of time look slavery is not
acceptable anymore humans used it for a
long time the the better Parts have
stayed with us
I'd like to believe that we can write
down you know if a then B if x then y
but humans just don't operate that way I
mean Humanity thought slavery in the
Holocaust was a great idea they went
along with it right
but then it was challenged and because
it was challenged because people said
hey this is not okay hey this is wrong I
was challenged with bombs right and by
force so but it started with speech and
people and that that's where it began
World War II the the Allied front in
World War II did not begin with speech
it began with airplanes and guns no no
no no obviously there was Weaponry but
obviously what led up to it was a bunch
of meetings which a bunch of talks with
a bunch of escalations a bunch of things
that were related to trade were related
to embargo so it was a slow Chamberlain
smoke and Churchill shot right the the
reason the left holds the position they
do is their argument is that Hitler uh
was allowed to hold his rallies and to
indoctrinate and to expand and he was
not sufficiently opposed and his his
rhetoric was winning people over because
of their desperation he was basically
exploiting their grievances to trick
them into the psychotic idea he was also
suppressing people he didn't agree with
he had control of the media not that
that's afterwards how did he rise to the
point where he could do that he
manipulated and exploited people's
emotions their grievances over over
World War one and and the the debt to
France things like that the poor economy
he gave them things they wanted and then
Twisted that into his insane grievance
it's also worth remembering because you
know everyone always makes World War II
comparisons because it's like the only
thing that anyone's ever so Stalin no
yeah but but you know the the thing
that's important to remember before we
get to down the rabbit hole of thinking
we live in you know the time in the
1930s or 20s or something Weimar Germany
was completely destroyed you know money
was worthless mothers and daughters were
were holding prostitution teams together
like that that degree of desperation is
uh is you know not akin to something
we're seeing now but the libs exploit
this and they say well you know we're
just always living in the lead-up to
Hitler thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time